Caroline replaced up with will be the  support for power we think this bad  let's make this message my life  let's do this betch how to kill a nice  right that one right there oh yes  [ __ ] [ __ ] its lucky let's stick with  that mouth yes yes yes tell me again why  we're wasting time is good with you  vocal shaping a legend we don't even  know it exists you're alive ionno flick  a drink I have to admit I didn't think  we'd be seeing you again I bet I  misjudged you you're definitely  Stormcloak material it's time we made  this official you're ready to take the  old avec before you're on about you must  also pledged unswerving loyalty to let I  to sweat your love in health as Hallows  is my even to my lord all health which  means you could track a tangy watching  us you're a storm